should it should it be grape if if um if
a girl says she's on birth control and
she's not
oh
should that be grape oh great because he
consented to
or let's let's say an iud girl says she
has an iud yeah he consented to sex with
the iud let's say she doesn't have one
should that be grape yeah surely that's
equivalent to stealthy because there you
know there's some laws in the u.s that
they're saying um if a guy takes off the
condom that's great
yeah we call that stealth in here oh i
don't i don't know yeah okay british
terms yeah
i think if you're if you're choosing if
two people are choosing to have
unprotected sex
i also choose to potentially have that
consequence it also depends if you're
having casual sex or if you're in a if
you're dating
and or if you're in a relationship i
think with casual sex you need to know
you both need to know what you're
dealing with and you know um if it's
just
having casual then you're going to be
using you're both using something i also
think as well that you need to
communicate if you're dating someone
you're saying right i don't want to have
kids right now i just want to well i'm
saying if she lies so if she if she said
because there's a lot of girls that want
to trap guys yeah right if he's if he's
big enough yeah yeah
so if a girl lies to him and he gives
consent for
sex with an iud and she doesn't have one
should that be grape
and the same thing with a condom if he
if she consents to sex with a condom and
then he takes it off is that grape
i think they both are if one
i think
taking taking it off when you're in the
middle of it can only be seen as grape
but equivocally if a woman lies the only
problem is obviously in the eyes of the
law how do you prove that she lied but i
think it should be
i think great when you look at grape
grape is
an unconsent of that act right and that
like when you're taking if you're if a
woman's gonna say to a man oh yeah i'm
on birthday but she's not
and then she ends up having his baby
like
that's very challenging that's trap
there's a manipulative fight that's a
great thing
that's just a woman being like a bad
person that's a great baby
it's a great baby
you stole his semen he's so excited so
so do you would you say the same thing
then for a woman if a guy takes off the
condom is it the same
if there was a wood so would i if the
woman if the woman consents to sex with
a condom yeah man's not feeling it he
takes it off is that great
i don't think he's great because she's
consented to the act to the exact same
yeah
okay it's consistent
yeah what about you guys you would say
that would be great for both or we could
say essay instead if you want to make it
a lesser
that's one thing i would say i do think
it's mad that for taking it off and
obviously i'm not a lawyer you can get
the same as jumping a woman in the
street and dragging into is that here um
yeah you get the same you have four
years either way shut up if he takes off
a condom yeah you get four years shut up
so it's like i find it's mad that you
can get four years for that but then you
can just pick a random girl and get the
same chances
i only i heard that they might have
introduced that in california but i did
not know that was the one no no here if
you do that and they prove it you'll go
into prison for four years but there's
no i bet there's no law for the
equivalent which is a woman saying she's
on no no no no d or even stealing a
condom
no
nothing because you you guys heard about
that like the nba issued statements
saying that like the um players need to
flush their condoms because girls were
stealing them wow oh well i didn't know
that wow yeah and it was so prep i mean
think about that's the number one way
nba players go broke
they get the wrong girl pregnant
and that's what i'm saying it's another
thing like it's another fail-safe for a
woman's bad decisions
because you picked the wrong guy and now
you get paid for it and there's women
out there
yeah and there's some women that don't
like do that right like i'm not saying
every single girl like like takes part
in child support but like like at the
end of the day it's another fail-safe
for women's bad decisions and that's why
it's almost like we're children because
we get bailed out of every bad decision
that we make we sleep around
slut-shaming we get fat fat phobia
there's no there's no equivalence of
these for men then if we sleep around
and get pregnant we have abortion as an
option we have adoption as an option
there's bailout for that we get married
and then we get divorced which is you
know bad like bad decision you can get
alimony or child support
so it's every every bad decision that we
make we're always bailed out
i think like you know but some some of
those but not all of them but definitely
some of those bailouts are also bailouts
for
both parties involved which ones
both like the man and the woman like if
for example abortion let's say a couple
don't want to have a child then they're
both
by that woman going through that but
it's a hundred percent the woman's
decision
because that can mean you can like me
and you can have sex and you know
you get pregnant yeah and let's say i
want the baby but you don't want the
baby i have no power whether you get rid
of the baby or not i just have to like
you know tell you that i want the baby
and hope that you keep the baby because
i said but if you in your head said i do
not want this baby
there's nothing that i can actually
physically whatever there's nothing i
can do by law there's nothing that i can
actually do to stop you from getting rid
of that baby yeah that's so true
and then even even like governments pay
out single mothers they don't pay out
single fathers but don't you think
there's something then that's something
wrong with the system because like i
said previously when i was when i was
dating that person who had two kids you
know there were times where he was a
good father and there were times where
he would go into the court like go to
court and try and
you know get joint custody of his kids
and it would be so hard yes like that it
would be so difficult almost impossible
and it went on for years
and and then and then you hear and then
you do hear stories of women who go to
court and they do get that favor they do
that's but that's but that's
the court system that we currently have
right yeah that's what i'm saying it's
like that's another way women are bailed
out of bad decisions because they can
leave break up the home and they still
get custody
on the chick and a check
and even and women own two-thirds of
consumer debt right so we get homeless
what are their women's shelters
there's not really men's shelters like
that i mean there's like one or two but
not not the same way there's women's
shelters that's true i don't even know
what i don't know what the real-time
like
real-time data is for that
in the uk if you're a woman and you have
a child out of wedlock and you're
homeless yeah you get council house so
quickly quick if you're single if you're
a single dad they'll tell you to get a
job big man and sort it out or your kids
are going into care yeah you're not
getting council house like that yeah
that's but i think that's a massive flaw
in again the system is
it's not a floor in the system because
the system is made for men to work
in order to put into the system and
allow women
to cash out of the system so when people
talk about flaws it's it's not a flaw
it's how the system's going to work and
obviously as as pearl has been saying
like
women are 80 of the consumer base so
they know the system knows that if men
are working and putting into the system
the women are going to take the money
out and spend it on these luxuries that
you that women love you know bags
clothes and you know women are very
spontaneous with their spending do you
understand so and like when we talk
about for example the welfare state and
we talk about general double standards
this is not us as us as it meant
advocating that the double standards
shouldn't exist our problem is we accept
these double standards like no man who
pays on a first date
is bothered
unless you're a broke guy and you're a
loser and you probably don't deserve
[ __ ] anyway but most men
are not bothered but but our problem is
when a man now comes out and says
cheating for a man and woman is
different or then women just lose the
plot about it and it becomes a double
standard conversation
and that's why when we talk about this
is just that
okay